lorsqu'il sera Messi
courant sur le terrain
mettant le ballon au fond du filet,
ou Federer faisant un service à Wimbledon ?
A votre avis, que ressentira-t-il
lorsqu'il descendra le versant d'une montagne
à plus de 100 kilomètres à l'heure
comme un skieur lors d'une descente olympique ?
Je pense qu'il pourrait y avoir des soldes sur les couches pour adultes.
(Rires)
Mais ce n'est pas encore de la réalité augmentée.
Ce n'est que de la réalité virtuelle (RV).
Comment obtient-on de la réalité augmentée (RA) ?
On obtient de la réalité augmentée
quand les coachs, les managers et les propriétaires
regardent les informations qui affluent,
que les gens veulent voir, et qu'ils se disent :
« Comment pouvons-nous utiliser cela pour rendre nos équipes meilleures ?
Comment est-ce qu'on l'utilise pour gagner des matchs ? »
Parce que les équipes utilisent toujours la technologie pour gagner des matchs.
Ils aiment gagner. Ça leur rapporte de l'argent.
Un bref historique de la technologie en NFL.
En 1965, les Colts de Baltimore
ont mis un bracelet à leur quarterback
pour lui permettre de jouer plus vite.
Cette année-là, ils ont gagné le Super Bowl.
D'autres équipes ont fait de même.
Plus de personnes ont regardé les matchs parce que c'était plus excitant.
Ça allait plus vite.
En 1994, la NFL a mis des émetteurs radio
dans les casques des quarterbacks,
et plus tard, des défenseurs.
Plus de personnes ont regardé les matchs parce que le jeu était plus rapide.
C'était plus divertissant.
En 2023, imaginez que vous êtes un joueur
retournant vers la mêlée,
votre prochain coup est affiché
juste devant vos yeux sur votre visière en plastique
que vous portez déjà actuellement.
Plus besoin de s'inquiéter de tactiques oubliées.
Plus besoin de s'inquiéter de la mémorisation des stratégies.
Vous n'avez qu'à aller sur le terrain et à réagir.
Et les coachs n'attendent que ça,
parce que des tactiques loupées font perdre des matchs,
et les coachs détestent perdre des matchs.
Les coachs sont virés à cause de matchs perdus.
Et ils ne veulent pas être virés.
Mais la réalité augmentée n'est pas juste
des stratégies améliorées.
La réalité augmentée, c'est aussi une manière
de collecter toutes les données et de les utiliser en temps réel
pour améliorer votre façon de jouer.
A quoi est-ce que ça ressemblerait ?
Un dispositif très simple consisterait en une caméra
à chaque coin du stade, orientée vers le sol,
donnant une vue d'ensemble
de toutes les personnes sur le terrain.
Il y a aussi les informations provenant des capteurs dans les casques
et des accéléromètres,
des technologies sur lesquelles on travaille actuellement.
Vous prenez toutes ces informations, et vous les envoyez à vos joueurs.
Les bonnes équipes envoient ces informations de façon à ce que
les joueurs puissent s'en servir.
Les mauvaises sont surchargées d'informations.
Ça distingue les bonnes des mauvaises équipes.
Aujourd'hui, le département informatique
est aussi important que celui de recherche de talents,
et l'extraction de données n'est plus réservée aux geeks.
C'est aussi pour les sportifs. Qui l'aurait dit ?
A quoi cela ressemblerait sur le terrain ?
Imaginez que vous soyez quarterback.
Vous prenez le ballon et vous reculez.
Vous parcourez le terrain des yeux à la recherche d'un receveur libre.
Tout à coup, un flash lumineux
sur la gauche de votre visière vous fait savoir,
que le défenseur dans l'angle mort revient comme un éclair.
Normalement, vous ne devriez pas pouvoir le voir,
mais le système de réalité augmentée vous le fait savoir.
Vous montez dans la poche*. [Terme de football]
Un autre flash vous indique un receveur libre.
Vous lancez le ballon, mais vous êtes percuté
juste au moment où vous lancez.
Le ballon est dévié.
Vous ne savez pas où il va atterrir.
Cependant, sur la visière du receveur,
il voit une parcelle d'herbe éclairée,
et il sait comment réajuster.
Il y va, attrape le ballon,
court, touchdown.
La foule est en délire et les fans sont avec lui
à chaque instant,
regardant depuis toutes les perspectives.
C'est quelque chose qui va générer
une forte excitation durant le match.
Ça poussera beaucoup de monde à regarder,
parce que les gens veulent vivre cette expérience.
Les fans veulent être sur le terrain.
Ils veulent être leur joueur préféré.
La réalité augmentée prendra part dans le sport,
parce qu'elle est trop profitable.
Mais la question que je vous pose est
est-ce que c'est la seule raison pour laquelle nous souhaitons
utiliser la réalité augmentée ?
Allons-nous seulement l'utiliser pour notre
panem et circenses, notre divertissement ?
Parce que je pense que nous pouvons utiliser la réalité augmentée
pour quelque chose de plus.
Je pense que nous pouvons utiliser la réalité augmentée
pour favoriser l'empathie
au cœur de l'espèce humaine elle-même,
en montrant réellement à quelqu'un
ce que l'on ressent
lorsque l'on est dans la peau de quelqu'un d'autre.
Nous savons que cette technologie vaut le coup
pour les fédérations sportives.
Sa valeur est de plusieurs milliards de dollars par an.
Mais que vaut cette technologie
pour un professeur dans une salle de classe,
essayant de montrer à une brute
à quel point ses actions sont blessantes
du point de vue de la victime ?
Que vaut cette technologie
pour un homosexuel ougandais ou russe
essayant de montrer au monde ce que c'est
que de vivre persécuté ?
Que vaut cette technologie
pour un commandant Hadfield ou un Neil deGrasse Tyson
essayant d'intéresser une génération d'enfants
plus à l'espace et aux sciences
qu'aux rapports trimestriels et aux Kardashian ?
Mesdames et messieurs, la réalité augmentée
arrive.
Les questions que nous posons, les choix que nous faisons,
et les défis auxquels nous faisons face
ne dépendent que de nous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)